Heat.
[music]
Heat. Heat. Heat.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Hello and welcome to another episode of
What's Up Prof. Goodday, Walter.
>> I'm waiting for you to [laughter] say
that.
>> How are you? Are you going to say that
as well?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. People who say, "I never answered
that question." So, let me say I'm fine.
[laughter]
>> I'm glad you're fine.
>> How are you?
>> Fine.
>> Why? [laughter] We're living in troubles
times. Why are you fine?
>> I'm keeping my anchor to the where it's
supposed to be.
>> I see. Okay.
>> Yes. We're in troubles times, that's for
sure.
>> Yes. But uh no need to complain because
we've been waiting for them for a long
time. [laughter]
>> That's for sure as well.
>> Yes.
>> The problem is some people say it is not
so.
>> Well, that's their problem. [laughter]
Let's open with a word of prayer. Our
heavenly father,
we are in momentous times and we ask
that you please in discuss in this
discussion, please help us again that we
can [gasps] talk [sighs] and deliberate
on what you want us to say in Jesus
name. Amen.
>> Amen.
Well, Martin,
will you stand? And I think the backdrop
is very appropriate. There's an iceberg
ahead and the only way to deal with it
is not to brush by it like the Titanic
and rip your side open and sink.
>> Yeah.
>> Even though you're supposedly
unsinkable.
>> Mhm.
>> But [clears throat] to meet it. And if
you bump into a iceberg like that full
force with the front,
then the chances that uh the ship will
be terribly shaken are pretty good.
Right. Hey, that's for sure.
>> Do you think some could fall overboard?
>> Yes.
>> A real
shake.
>> So, when you know there's a iceberg
ahead and the command is meet it.
>> Meet it.
>> Isn't that a good time to fasten your
seat belt?
>> Yes. So that you don't go overboard.
>> And add a little bit of super glue.
>> So that you don't go overboard as you
said. What do you think?
>> Definitely. I think the time is now.
>> All right. So, we're not going to do
rocket science in this one. We're not
going to talk about the events in part
two. We'll do do that. We'll talk about
some of the events taking place now. But
just uh a little grounding again into
the basics of what the confrontation is
all about and why it is necessary to
meet the iceberg.
>> Yeah. Yeah. The thing is, um, we've done
so many episodes and it's been so many
years. I mean, there were some questions
you sent me of people and then I went
back to 2021 and I saw, wow, maybe we
can just refresh some of these things
again because I don't know how many
people go back and see all of that.
>> No, they don't. How many are there now?
I don't even know how many there are
just of the WhatsApp prof series.
>> Yeah, 233 or this is 234.
>> Okay. So people don't want to rehash 234
[laughter]
videos of an hour and a half or longer
each, right?
>> I understand that. So we want to do a
little summary of what the real issue is
and why it is important that we prepare
for meeting this iceberg.
>> Yeah.
>> In actual fact, had Protestantism done
its work, there would be no iceberg.
>> That's true.
>> Yeah. Because then they would have
completely
separated and
>> and kept the faith
>> and the true faith.
>> Yes.
>> The pure one.
>> Now they all confused.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes.
So Martin, let's just recap again. I
know we've shown this before, but this
is uh prevatican 2 Catholicism.
>> Yeah.
>> And its thinking. And uh if we go to the
Vatican 2 documents
then one of the previous popes Ratzinger
who was Pope Benedict remember
>> made it absolutely clear that the
Catholic position from the council of
Trent had absolutely not changed.
So it is just the way in which it was
presented in Vatican 2 which made some
people believe that the Catholic Church
had compromised and moved away from some
of its positions.
But Ratzinga made it absolutely clear by
then he was not Benedict yet. He was uh
the head of the congregation of doctrine
and faith which is the inquisition
>> which was first run by another order of
the Catholic Church but eventually run
by the Jesuits.
>> Mhm.
>> And uh their seat was in Rome in the
very building where the Inquisition was.
>> Mhm. And he said, "Other churches are
not sisters of ours [snorts] because
she's the mother. Therefore, the others
can only be children, right? And they
[snorts] have to return to the mother."
>> And that's the whole basis of the
ecumenical movement.
>> And if you join that ecumenical
movement, basically it's an
acknowledgment that you want to set
aside the doctrinal differences for the
sake of peace, harmony, and unity.
That's exactly what it is. And so the
true doctrine of Jesus is being set
aside.
>> Correct. And Pope Francis made it
abundantly clear that doctrine was not
to be a criterion.
>> Yeah.
>> In the ecumenical movement, we had to
concentrate only on those things upon
which they agreed and the rest was set
aside. Now the fortunate thing is the
things that they sometimes agreed upon
were not biblical.
>> Yeah.
>> But were based on tradition in both
Catholicism and Protestantism.
>> And in our discussions with Lenox and
with Douglas Wilson, it became
abundantly clear that Protestantism was
not going to turn its back on tradition.
>> No. but uh was going to cling to it in
spite of a very clear biblical
counterargument.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, and that's that was made
clear.
>> So, this whole and we've seen it now in
the uh the speeches that have been made
and all of this about church and state
being united. Trump has made it
abundantly clear
>> they're not going to back down of from
this now.
>> So, let's just go again to this video. I
know we've shown it before, but just to
make abundantly clear what conservative
Catholicism believes. The Catholic
Church, the human dimension has been
overrun by the Protestant heresy. When
we talk about the church and nice,
that's actually what we're talking
about. That large group of Catholics who
have joined themselves to the lie that
is Protestantism. Protestantism is a lie
because it is a heresy. We've been
hitting this theme all week. And
heresies like sisms lead to hell for the
unrepentant. Here's the rub. Every
single last one of those beliefs, they
get from Catholicism. Period. They
didn't come up with those on their own.
They belong to us. We're happy to share
them. Just take them all. When Martin
Luther and his cohort were walking out
of the church, they took a few things
with them, those beliefs among them. And
then over the centuries, Luther's
followers have taken those Catholic
treasures and distorted them almost
beyond recognition. In the area of
theology, for example, Protestants don't
have a clue about sacred scripture,
although they all dance around like they
do. They interpret it for themselves and
they fill in the blanks as they go
along, essentially making it up. What it
creates is an environment where instead
of being instructed by scripture, you
instruct it. Protestants impose their
personal beliefs on the texts and they
twist them to mean whatever they like
the most. They're not a church. They're
normally nothing more than a nonprofit
organization that meets once or twice a
week and occasionally gets something
correct in scripture, but most of the
time makes a shipwreck of the sacred
texts because they have denied the
authority of the Catholic Church who
gave the world the Bible. It's our book.
you don't take it and then get to tell
us what it means. And then having denied
the authority of the church to correctly
interpret it even though again the
church produced it. Then they claim a
right which they do not possess the
ability to interpret scripture. It
denies the efficacy of the sacraments
most especially the real presence of
Christ body, blood, soul and divinity in
the Eucharist. It twists and distorts
sacred scripture in the egotistical air
of telling congregations what they want
to hear. We're not essentially all the
same. Meaning in essence, they deny the
church. And he who denies the church
denies Christ himself. Not a single book
of the Bible, for example, itself claims
to be inspired. Not one. Yet Protestants
go on and on about the Bible being
inspired. Well, since the Bible itself
doesn't even claim that, then why do
they believe it? Martin, a moment of
silence [laughter]
seems appropriate for the poor man's
soul.
>> Yeah. Well,
>> okay. So, that type of thinking
is alive and well and living within
Catholicism.
>> Yeah.
>> And although the facade to the outside
is reconciliatory,
in the inside it is exactly what we see
here. And those partakers in the
movements in the world aren't there
either belong to secret societies or
organizations that have this philosophy
whether they be called oppus day who
torture themselves on a daily basis to
remind them of their allegiance to the
pope
>> and uh who usurps Christ and steals his
prerogatives.
uh a system that is welld deserved of
the title antichrist.
And then you have uh the Knights of
Columbus who are busy with their
political agendas to bring these
doctrines into the mainstream. and they
link themselves publicly to
Protestantists
uh who I would believe uh in my personal
capacity,
some of them of which are probably
Jesuit agents,
>> pretending to be Protestants.
>> Yeah.
>> And not adhering to the word at all, but
to some emotion.
And then the arrogant statements about
the Catholic Church having given the
world the Bible. The Catholic Church
didn't exist when the Old Testament was
written and it didn't exist when the New
Testament was written. And all that they
did was pervert the eastern manuscripts
in their nnosticistic thinking and then
added a whole lot of dril which is
called the apocrypha which contradict
every word
>> in the Bible and all scripture is
inspired. Doesn't the Bible say that?
>> It says it. He says no not one book
claims to be inspired. The
[clears throat] only thing that they
gave to the world is a corrupted version
which was called the Vulgate.
>> And the Vulgate uh was declared
infallible.
And the next pope after the
infallibility declaration ordered more
than 2,000 changes, so much for his
infallibility.
>> And that was the Latin version that was
available until you had the uprising of
the Turks. and the fleeing of the
Eastern Orthodox Church with the
manuscripts that were based on the
Antioch stream.
>> Yeah.
>> Coming into the West and those
manuscripts were used to translate the
Bible which gave the Catholic Church
heartburn
>> very much so. And so they created the
Jesuit order
>> in order to counteract what they had
been teaching all along.
So Martin, perhaps we should go back to
the beginning.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. Now,
if I take my Bible,
>> maybe I can just quickly tell
>> people wanted to know what kind of Bible
this is.
>> We've got hundreds of people. So, it's
the mission study Bible. Let me just see
yours. Is that also
>> It's the mission study Bible.
>> Yes. They can just show it to the people
there on the camera. Um, and they can
just search for it. Is this mission
study bible with LG White uh commentary?
>> Commentary. Okay. Now, Martin, if you go
to the book of Revelation,
let's just make it quite clear as to
what happens over there. In Revelation
chapter 2, we have the beginning of the
story about the seven churches.
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> And this falls within the
uh historic part of the kayastic
structure of the book of revelation.
So you have the historic arm, you have
the historic climax and [clears throat]
then you have the esqueological arm. Now
when it falls into the historic arm,
then conservative uh commentators will
try to fit the events into a historic
context
because it leads up to current day
events in Revelation 11
onwards 12, 13, 14 with some recaps of
past history. But once you get to
Revelation 13, 14, etc., then we are
dealing with with the events that are
now current.
>> Yeah.
>> And the rest are esqueological events as
to how this will play out.
>> Revelation 14, of course, also very
important. So if you go to to Revelation
chapter 2, it starts off with the first
movement, the first church
>> because this is addressed to the
churches. Yeah. So obviously we're
dealing with the churches and we're
dealing with the the philosophy of the
churches and the teaching of the
churches and we're dealing with the the
conditions which they face.
Now I'm not going to do a Bible study on
the seven churches. Now that's not our
point here.
>> The first church was pure. It was a
church that had the truth.
But they were becoming complacent.
>> Uh-huh.
>> So they were falling asleep.
>> They Yeah. They were becoming pu uh
complacent. So it says, "I know thy
works and thy labor and thy patience,
and how they can bear them that are
evil, and thrived them which say that
they are apostles and are not, and has
found them liars." Now, how do you find
someone a liar? You must have a basis in
order to determine truth from error,
right? You have to have the truth.
>> Okay. So, what was their basis?
>> The Bible.
>> All right. Was there a Catholic church
in this time?
>> No.
>> And was there a pope?
>> So, unfortunately, he couldn't help them
with his infallibility, right?
>> No. So, how would they been then able to
interpret the scripture then?
>> I don't know. These poor people were
popeless. [laughter]
It's such a ridiculous statement that,
you know, he would make me nauseious.
But nevertheless,
and then he talks about uh hast born and
has patience and for my name's sake,
thou has labored and has not fainted.
The early church was very active, right?
>> Mhm.
>> Okay. But then he says, you know, you've
you've lost your fire.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, what rekindled the fire? The
rekindling of the fire comes into the
next church which gets no rebuke.
Smirna and the word m there of course is
sweet incense, the smell of a sweet
savor. And these were the times when
Christians were martyed for their faith
and there was a persecution under the
Roman Empire and uh these people have
nothing but commendation from God. And
then you have a terrible time period
called Pergamum.
>> Yeah.
Now this is a time period when there was
a compromise with paganism
and this is the place that the Bible
says is where Satan has his seat.
>> Yes.
>> And that is because the Babylonian
priesthood had its seat in this very
place.
>> Yes. And all the colors are there you
know whether uh whatever the colors are
where they have their seat.
Now when we talk about seat we're
talking about the seat of authority. If
you jump to Revelation 13 there is
another seat
>> and the dragon gave him his seat
>> and his power and great authority. So
that seat has moved from Pergamum which
was the Babylonian priesthood to the
Roman Catholic priesthood.
So all that changed is the role players
but his philosophy is the same. It's an
antichrist philosophy.
>> Yes. So is this also the period when it
actually changed over from pagan Rome to
papal Rome?
>> That's included in it.
>> Okay. Because the first thing that
happened is the last king of the
Babylonian priesthood Atalus
>> bequeathed his title to Rome.
>> Now that is to pagan Rome.
>> Yeah.
>> And uh he had to take that title and he
had to take uh the vestments and the tie
>> and of course the Babylonian priesthood
was also into dagon worship. That's
where you get the fish head miter. which
is the fish god and he had to take the
divinity that came together with it and
the the Roman emperor emperors
at this time uh weren't quite so
arrogant as to utilize this title of
divinity until you get to Julius Caesar
>> then they had to be woripped as deities
>> and of course the Christians couldn't
worship them as deities and So a problem
arose and then you get eventually after
this terrible persecution of smirna the
smirna time period you have this period
of compromise [clears throat]
>> where constantine then adopts a quasi
Christianity
>> and paganism and Christianity fused
together.
This is a very dangerous thing.
>> And he says, "I have a few things
against you because you have them that
hold to the doctrine of
>> Balum
>> who taught Bailac to cast a stumbling
block before the children of Israel and
to eat things sacrificed unto idols and
to commit fornication."
Eat things sacrificed to idols. Mhm.
>> So, did some form of uh idolatry come in
where there was a sacrifice that had to
be eaten that had
idolatry attached to it? Well, somewhere
in this time period and in the rise of
Roman Catholicism,
>> they started switching over from a
totally faith-based religion in Jesus
Christ as the atoning sacrifice of God
and his high priestly office.
And the earthly priesthood had come to
an end.
>> Yes. So the Bible talks about ministers
of the gospel whereas in the Old
Testament it was priests.
>> Now priest always brought a sacrifice.
>> So Martin if the priesthood was
abolished
because the curtain tore from top to
bottom. Right.
>> Mhm.
>> Then that priesthood was transferred to
Christ.
>> Yes. who became our high priest. And
according to Hebrews, he ascended on
high and he is interceding on our
behalf. And according to Hebrews, we now
had direct access to God.
>> Yeah.
>> Is that correct?
>> That's correct. He's officiating as a
priest currently in heaven.
>> Yes. So if you follow the blueprint of
the earthly sanctuary then at his
ascension he must have gone into the
holy place.
>> Yeah. to perform the mediation. And he
would be seen standing in front the of
the altar of incense
applying the prayers of the saints to
his mediation and to his character and
making them acceptable to God. So he's
the one officiating in that
[clears throat] capacity. And revelation
makes it quite clear in revelation
chapter one that he is walking amongst
the candlesticks. Yeah. And the
candlesticks are in the first chamber.
>> So what was established
when Christ came to this world? His
mission as we said in a previous one was
in the outer court.
>> Yes.
>> Because he was a Judean.
>> Mhm. And only the levetical priesthood
was allowed to officiate in the holy and
the most holy.
>> Yeah.
>> So he fulfilled the outer court. He
became the lamb of God that was
sacrificed and he was killed outside of
the temple and the walls. And on Golgata
he paid the price for our sins. And when
he was resurrected he said do not detain
me. do not hold me back. I am going to
my father.
And there he was inaugurated as the high
priest.
>> So that was like you mentioned in that
episode. I can't I'll just put a link
into it. Um
>> inaugurating
the whole
>> sanctuary.
>> Sanctuary.
>> Yes. And he came back
>> and he told them all power has been
given unto them. And the disciples had
direct access to him.
Was there a pope?
>> No.
>> Now the Catholic Church will claim there
was one and his name was Peter.
>> But he had uh a very tumultuous
existence and even Paul on occasion had
to rebuke him for hypocrisy.
And his statement that uh or the
Catholic statement that he is the rock
is of course a distortion of scripture.
>> It's true
>> because the statement that he made
>> you are the son of the living God. You
are the Christ. That is the foundation
of the Christian faith. So from that
moment onwards the Christian had access
>> directly to God as the mediator.
>> Yeah. So when Peter was referring to it
he made Jesus the rock and Jesus
acknowledged it but saying you are Peter
and I am the on this rock
>> correct
>> myself I'm building my church.
>> And Jesus made it quite clear when he
said when they said to him your mother
is waiting outside and your brethren. He
says, "Though they do the will of my
father, they are my mother and my
brethren and my [clears throat] sisters,
etc."
>> And then he said to the disciples, you
shall not lord it over each other. You
shall not be like the Gentiles. You are
brothers and sisters. You must have
unity of thought. There was no boss man.
No,
>> it's very clear.
>> So there was no pope either, no matter
how much these people tried to introduce
one. And the priesthood had been
transferred from an earthly priesthood
to Christ the mediator. So there was no
need of a sacrifice. And the Bible makes
it absolutely clear which that uh
deceived gentleman claims had no
inspiration
that by one sacrifice he has forever
made perfect. Forever. Correct. So
Martin, was there any need then of
introducing a new priesthood?
>> No.
>> That
>> no.
>> No.
>> Was there any need to introduce a new
mediator?
>> Definitely not.
>> Was there any need for the intercession
of priests and popes and saints?
>> No.
>> No. You had direct access to Christ. Did
they eventually replace the earthly
pastors pastoral work where you are
equal with your brethren and that is
made quite clear in the book of acts at
the first council that there was no boss
there.
>> Yeah.
>> And that the decision was made by the
apostles by the elders and the brethren
which of course they despise. Therefore
they take it out of their modern
perverted versions. Yeah.
>> So that they are the kingpins who make
the decision decisions and goam like you
and me have nothing to say. Right.
>> So Martin what happened in this time
period the earthly church system
>> again took the prerogatives which
belonged alone to Christ.
>> Yes.
>> All right. And it meets its fulfillment
in the next church which is
>> Teotira.
>> And in this church then you have moved
directly to a period of total apostasy.
And that's why in verse 21 and it says I
gave her space to repent of her
fornication.
>> In other words, her apostasy towards
God. This is now the church of the
Middle Ages. This is Roman Catholicism.
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> Uh and she repented not
>> because Rome doesn't change. She claims
infallibility. If she were to change,
she would shoot herself in the foot with
a with a 12 ball shotgun.
>> Yeah.
>> And she hasn't done so to this day.
And so he says, I will cast her on a bed
of suffering
with them that commit adultery with her
into great tribulation except they
repent of their deeds. And we've just
heard they won't repent of their deeds.
>> And then Martin, you get to the church
in chapter three, which is called
>> Sardis,
>> which is the church of the reformation.
And it says, "And unto the angel of the
church in Sardis, these things says he
that has the seven spirits of God and
the seven stars." Now, he already
defined those are the pastoral
components of God's church. So all of
these apostasies were coming in and they
were starting to leak into the church.
They were always faithful groups.
>> Yeah.
>> They were terribly persecuted because
they didn't go along with this apostasy.
They are the true church of God like the
Valdenzians and the Albanzians
and elements of the Celtic church and
the Ethiopian church and of the Eastern
churches etc.
And then he says, "Be watchful and
strengthen the things which remain."
Which means a lot of things have been
taken away.
>> Yeah.
>> That are ready to die. That's a very sad
state of affairs. For I have not find
thy works perfect before God.
>> So there were some things missing.
>> Some things missing. And the gentleman
in the video rightly said that they took
a lot of traditions from Roman
Catholicism and kept them instead of
expounding them
>> and putting them into the garbage can
where they belong.
>> Yeah.
>> One of them being the sacraments.
>> Mhm.
>> Because if they were true, Martin, then
something that you perform, a ritual,
will have salvational power,
>> which is of course nonsense. only the
transformation of the heart and an
acceptance of Christ as your personal
savior and not another mediator. Uh 10
Hail Marys and a rosary just won't cut
it.
>> Therefore, there's a serious problem
here. So, if you want to go to the the
uh the retributions which God sent on
the churches,
then I would jump to Revelation chapter
8. Okay. Now in Revelation chapter 7 or
even before that in Revelation chapter 6
you have the seven seals.
>> Now the seven seals also tell the same
story as what we heard in the seven
churches and it follows that sequence
and it displays the gospel heralds as
horses running across the earth. Yeah.
And the first one of course having the
unadulterated gospel is a white horse
>> that was
>> and then it becomes a red horse and
remember Smeirna was the time of
persecution so that is martyrdom and
blood
>> and then it becomes a black horse
>> that's Pergamum bringing in all
>> paganism
>> paganistic doctrines
>> and then you have a pale horse which is
the Roman Catholic system which is dead.
Yeah,
>> it's dead. It's pale. It's a skeleton.
It's gone. All right.
>> So, it follows that same sequence. Now,
why is it gone? Because it has gotten
rid of Christ as the mediator. They've
set up an earthly system and they've set
up the mass.
>> Yeah. Actually, they set up the
Antichrist system.
>> All right. Now, isn't that idol idolatry
and teaching people to eat food
sacrificed to idols?
>> Yes.
>> Correct. So that's idolatry because by
one sacrifice he has forever made
perfect and Rome cannot escape that
theology because they claim that the
sacrifice of the mass is one and the
same with the sacrifice of the cross. So
they cannot [clears throat] repudiate
that because they are so-called
infallible.
Now, Protestantism
did correct that and said, "No, the mass
is just a reminder." And let's get rid
of the word mass, by the way,
>> and let's get rid of the word eukarist.
And let's just call it holy communion.
>> Mhm.
>> Is a reminder of the one sacrifice that
has forever made perfect. So modern
there were judgments.
>> Mhm.
>> That affected the church as it moved
from a pure gospel
to a purified gospel the smir time
>> to the compromised gospel to the dead
gospel.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. There were scavengers which
came. Now, if you go back to ancient
Israel
when the people of God
uh became apostate,
>> how did God deal with it?
>> Well,
it's harsh. They were either in um
exile, taken in exile.
>> Who took them into exile?
>> The heathen nations.
>> Ah.
>> Mhm.
>> So, when they were apostate, it was
either the Philistines that controlled
them.
>> Yeah.
or the Moabites together with the
Ammonites or the Syrians or the
Babylonians,
they were chastised.
>> Yeah.
>> To bring them to their senses. And of
course, all of them repented after those
chastisements. Right.
>> Why are you laughing? [laughter]
Sometimes there was a a big repentance
going on and it only lasted for quite a
little while.
>> Yes. And then they would kill everybody
that was associated with the one that
brought about the repentance.
>> Yes.
>> All right. So he used pagan nations.
Right. Now the same happened in
Christendom.
>> Yeah.
>> He brought pagan nations to attack.
>> And uh the Roman Empire had become
Christianized.
But it was a compromised paganized
Christianity.
>> So is it the same as what happened in
Israel?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> Exactly the same.
>> So then all of a sudden the Huns arrive
and there's a massive scourge and they
they are threatened to being wiped out
etc etc. Right? And then eventually
uh God relents and the Huns disappear
from history. And then one Gothic tribe
after the other comes and beats up Rome
and
>> you know brings in other and and these
were now all Christianized. But uh the
Roman Empire was beaten to a pulp
>> by one invasion after the other. Whether
it was the Ostrogoths, whether it was
the Visigoths, whether it was the
Heruli,
uh they were beaten up, right?
And modern, why did God bring these
scers? So, you know, if we go to the
trumpets.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, some people want to throw the
trumpets into the future.
>> Mhm. But as I said, I believe that they
actually belong into
the historic arm.
>> Yeah.
>> Of with the rest
>> of the scriptures.
>> And the issue we don't have to go
through the entire trumpets and say
which scouage was it
>> because there are different opinions. It
doesn't really matter in my opinion
whether we get it exact or whether we
don't get it exact whether it was a
Laric or whether it was this one that
you know was part of the scarage. But uh
our pioneers interpreted some of these
things in the trumpet in a very specific
way. Some of the later ones they uh
combined with Turkey etc. and the
Ottoman Empire and the falling of the
Ottoman Empire. I'm not going to go
there. I'm interested in the first part.
So we go from chapter 8 from verse two.
And I saw there seven angels which stood
before God and to them were given seven
trumpets.
Now trumpets were always an announcement
of a great event.
>> Either a positive event like the giving
of the law on Mount Si.
Uh there will be a great sound of a
trumpet at the second coming of Christ.
But there were also rallies to war.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. And another angel came and stood
at the altar having a golden sensor. So
what altar is that?
>> Well, the altar of incense in the holy.
>> All right. Now, who's the only one who
actually mediates at the altar of
incense?
>> Christ.
>> Okay. Now, Christ is often associated
with the word angel. Even in the Old
Testament, the angel of the Lord
>> Mhm.
>> received worship. Therefore, he must
have been God.
>> Yeah.
>> Therefore, he must have been Christ.
Right.
>> Mhm.
>> So, another angel came and stood at the
altar having a golden sensor. I don't
believe any other created angel could
take that position. No.
>> Because the mediation is done on the
merits of Christ.
And there was given unto him much
incense.
>> Mhm.
>> That he should offer it with the prayers
of all saints upon the golden altar
which was before the throne. So there's
no question as to what altar that was.
>> Yeah.
>> So he was given much incense. Now this
incense is the prayers of the saints.
>> Mhm.
>> So how did the prayers of the saints get
to him? by the saints praying the s the
the prayers came to him as incense.
>> Okay. My question is where's the
intermediary? Where's the pope?
>> Nowhere. And there's no priest in there
as well except for Christ.
>> Where's St. Augustine or St. Francis or
Mary or St. Whoever?
>> Nobody.
>> Huh?
>> Nope.
>> Nowhere. No.
>> So your prayers go to who?
>> Jesus.
>> Go to Jesus. Go to God. Okay. So here he
has this
sensor
>> and he is mediating on behalf of his
saints. Now some of those prayers will
be prayers for forgiveness for sins
because the Holy Spirit convicts of sin,
righteousness and judgment. And some of
those prayers will be asking for help
under the circumstances in which they
are. asking for strength, asking for uh
the power to overcome your evil
tendencies. There's a whole plethora of
prayers in that and they ascending to
God and he has them in his sensor.
>> Okay?
And the smoke of the incense which came
with the prayers
of the saints ascended before God out of
the angel's hand. So who's the mediator?
>> Jesus. Jesus is the mediator.
>> He's the only one. There's no pope here.
>> And there is no saint. But now listen to
this.
And the angel took the sensor
and filled it with fire of the altar.
>> Mhm.
>> Now there was no fire on the altar of
incense.
>> No.
>> The only fire that there was was on the
altar of burnt offering which was
outside.
>> Outside.
>> Okay. What happened at that altar? The
lamb was sacrificed.
>> Correct.
>> Okay. So, the lamb was sacrificed there.
>> So, when he goes outside to take a coal
from that altar,
>> what is he referring to? To the
sacrifice of Christ, right?
>> Isn't it?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, he goes with the prayers where
he was officiating in the holy place. He
goes outside. is recapping what happened
before
>> the sacrifice of the lamb.
>> Yeah.
>> Which is himself.
>> That's it.
>> And he takes a coal.
>> Yeah.
>> And he places it in
this crucible in this sensor.
>> Now, does he take this back into the
holy place and offer it to God? The
answer is no. What does he do with it?
Let's see what he does with this.
>> And he cast it onto the earth. And there
were voices and thunderings and
lightnings and an earthquake. So here is
a retribution.
>> All right. So this prayerfilled
sensor with a reminder that he is the
sacrificial lamb [clears throat]
>> is not taken to the altar of incense and
and made acceptable to God through the
mediation of Christ. He throws it to the
ground. He throws it to the ground. Now
Martin, if you are angry and you hold
something in your hand and somebody
annoys it, what might you do with it?
>> Throw it to the ground.
>> You throw it to the ground.
>> So this is after he the saints prayers
has been mediated with him and gone to
the father. This is this is a separate
prayers.
>> There are prayers in there now.
>> Yeah. But this is
>> but he's going back
>> to [clears throat] this altar and he's
throwing the sensor with the coal and
the prayers down to ground.
>> Okay. What happened? Why would he do
that?
>> Martin, they had replaced the Messiah
>> and Jesus, the high priest, the
mediator, with an earthly mediation.
>> They had set up an earthly priesthood
and stole that which belonged to him and
appropriated it to themselves.
>> That's what they did. And therefore the
prayers that ascended from those people
were no longer acceptable to God.
>> Yeah. Because
>> and the sacrifice that he had made was
replaced with a mass, a perpetual
sacrifice which is an abomination and an
idolatry and food sacrificed to idols.
>> And therefore it had no value with God
whatsoever. And he threw it down. that
had gotten rid of his mediation
>> and then follow the scavengers that we
have here and we don't have to go into
them. The very last one will be the
seventh trumpet when Christ comes and he
cleans the slate. So Martin this church
this Roman Catholic church has taken the
position of Christ in the place of Jesus
Christ. And when the reformation came,
they replaced
the idolatry of the mass. And this was a
major major thing. And it was hard for
them.
>> They replaced it with the simple ritual
of a commemoration of the great
sacrifice that God had done.
>> And Catholicism was furious. That's why
they still are.
>> And now Martin when Protestantism
accepted the sacrifice of Christ and
said that you are saved by faith alone
in the atoning sacrifice of Christ.
Then Roman Catholicism blew a gasket
>> and they called it an anathema
>> and they wared against it and they
raised up the Jesuits to destroy it.
>> Yeah. And by the time you get to the
Oxford movement, when all the altars had
been thrown out of the churches and all
of these stupid statues had been thrown
out of the churches and replaced with a
simple
>> pulpit with the word of God as the
standard, what did they do?
They brought the altars back.
>> Yeah. They put the mass in there and the
first church to apostasize
at that level was the Church of England
which basically adopted the Roman
Catholic Mass again
>> and spat Christ in the face
>> in the process. Am I being too harsh?
>> Well, that's exactly what happened. And
if it's qualifying then as Antichrist,
then I don't believe you are too harsh.
>> All right. So this church, this church
of England
>> with all its Masonic symbols in their
churches,
this church which changed the
architecture
>> of St. Paul's Cathedral to become an
image of the Vatican
>> was the first Protestant movement back
to Rome. Mhm.
>> Then came the ecumenical movement
>> and that was also done by infiltration
again because um Henry Newman was
supposedly Protestant but then right
after this whole movement he became the
cardinal in the Catholic Church.
>> Exactly. If he were living today he
would be entirely woke
>> and it was the same [laughter] That's
good. Yeah.
>> Because he was woke.
>> Yeah. And at the same time, you had
Wescott and Hort
destroying the real Bible.
>> Yes.
>> And all of this infiltrated, right,
>> with their little ghostly guilds and
their little secret societies and
writing the rituals
>> and uh bringing in marology and uh uh
>> well occultic they bring brought in the
occult because they did seances and all
of this.
>> They were evil. Let's just put it that
way. And today those are the manuscripts
which the Roman Catholic Church
prescribes and loves where Jesus is made
a liar and his whole ministry is negated
to nothing less than a whimper or
nothing more than a whimper. Any case
that's the story. So mutton the Jesuits
and the counterreformation.
So let's just read what is written here
in the history of Protestantism by WY.
>> I think it's important because we've
just heard previously in that video how
bad Protestantism and how evil they are.
>> Yes.
>> According to the Vatican,
>> now according to uh the Bible Sardis, he
did not find their work complete. But he
does add, "There are those inside this
who will walk with me in white because
they lived up to the best light that
they had."
>> And I believe that counts right up until
today.
>> For sure.
>> Within the Protestant churches, there
are people that are living up to the
best light that they have. But they've
been brainwashed to forget the history
and to forget who the antichrist is and
to even remotely understand as to why he
is the antichrist. So Wy wrote that
Protestantism is not solely the outcome
of human progress. It is no mere
principle of perfectability inherent in
humanity and ranking as one of its
native powers in virtue of which when
society becomes corrupt, it can purify
itself. In other words, what he's
saying, Martin,
>> it is not a human movement. It is a
divine implant because we haven't got
the capacity to purify ourselves.
>> No. And the only thing that
Protestantism was supposed to do is
bring the truth back to light.
>> Correct. And when it is arrested in its
course by some external force,
it stops from exhaustion.
It can recruit its energies and set
forward a new on its path. It is neither
the product of the individual reason nor
the result of the joint thought and
energies of the species. Protestantism
is a principle which has its origin
outside of human society. It is a divine
graft on the intellectual and moral
nature of man whereby new vitalities and
forces are introduced into it and the
human stem yields henceforth a nobler
fruit. That's Protestantism.
And if you malign true Protestantism,
you are fighting against the Holy
Spirit. And the Catholic Church in my
opinion as a structure has already
committed the sin against the Holy
Spirit.
>> Not as people within it.
>> No. Important.
>> Because they do not understand the
ramifications.
>> As long as they live up to the light
that they've they have is like you said
earlier, God winks at it.
>> Yeah. All right. Let's take another
quote from uh one of my favorite
authors. Throughout Christianom,
Protestantism was menaced by formidable
foes. The first triumphs of the
Reformation passed. Rome summoned new
forces hoping to accomplish its
destruction. At this point, the order of
the Jesuits was created, the most cruel,
unscrupulous, and powerful of all the
champions of popery. Now, Martin, if you
think of the Dominican persecution
and you think of the other orders of
Catholicism and you think of the
Inquisition before the Jesuits even
existed, they were ruthless. Their
torture chambers are horror chambers.
>> And these people were the most ruthless
and the most cruel. So, they they
managed to outperform any form of evil
upon the earth.
There was no crime too great for them to
commit, no deception too base for them
to practice, no disguise too difficult
for them to assume, vowed to perpetual
poverty and humility. It was their
studied aim to secure wealth and power
to be devoted to the overthrow of
Protestantism
and the reestablishment of papal
supremacy.
So it continues by saying they wore this
garb of sanctity calling themselves the
society of Jesus etc.
>> But under this blameless exterior the
most criminal and deadly purposes were
often concealed. It was a fundamental
principle of the order that the end
justifies the means. So they could lie,
they could murder, they could torture,
they could do whatever was necessary.
By this code, lying, theft, perjury,
assassination were not only pardonable
but commendable.
And when they served the interests of
the church on various disguises, the
Jesus worked their way into offices of
state, clining up to be counselors of
kings and shaping the policy of nations.
And they were in the same position as
the calaldanss were in the Babylonian
times.
>> Uhhuh. The sorcerers and all of those.
>> Well, they were associated with the
sorcerers. The Jesuits had three
founders.
>> There was Ignatius of Lyola.
>> Mhm.
>> He was the military man that had the
visions
where experience and visions replace the
word of God. And he developed the
exercises of Lyola which today have been
transformed into many many varieties of
stupidity which have been swallowed by
Protestant churches as a road to God
when they are the road to hell.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Am I being too harsh modern?
>> That's this is how serious it is.
Because if you get caught up into in in
it before you know it you'll be
worshiping a deity that you think is
God.
>> Correct. But it is not.
>> And then there was Francis Zavia.
>> He didn't live very long. He was the one
that was on Vasco Dama's ships to go and
create trade routes with India. And the
Jesuit priests always went along to
convert the whole world to their way of
thinking and subjection to the papacy.
>> And most of these places where they
went, they were evangelized by early
Christians.
>> Correct. So when he got to India there
he found the Thomasite Christians which
were Sabbathke keepers he was horrified
because they weren't subject to the pope
>> and they kept the pagan Sunday rather
than the biblical Sabbath. So he
instituted the inquisition in Goa to
eradicate them and later they used the
nations that they had under their power
to overrun those nations and set in
place political structures which were
under the control of Rome.
>> Yeah.
>> So the the third one was [snorts] Peter
Faba. He was a German, he was an
intellectual and he was a philosopher.
And he brought the spiritual occultic
aspects into the fray. And together they
formed a illustrious pot of demon
activated doctrines.
>> Unholy trinity.
>> An unholy trinity. Very well put. Uh I
don't think we'll be very popular after
that, but [snorts] so be it. And to this
day, as we showed in the previous one,
they are commended on the Vatican web
pages because the Society of Jesus
focuses on intellectual research. any
research that makes God less than he is,
like evolution
>> with their uh Jesuit cronies who faked
the Pilttown hoax and all of these
issues and their influence over people
like Charles Darin educating, writing
God out of the curriculum, schools,
higher education, training the
presidents, uh bringing drugs into the
world. They are the most disgusting
organization ever to have disgraced this
planet. Some of the most prominent
universities in the world, especially in
the US, were founded originally by the
Jesuit order and some are still run by
it. And if they are not run directly by
it, they're run indirectly by it from
the boards where they have control.
The order was founded just before the
official counterreformation movement
began. So in other words, they were to
spearhead it. Does Rome admit to this
atrocity and this murder that these
people perpetrated?
>> They brag about it.
>> They brag about it. Okay. And then they
tell about, you know, the military
aspect, Ignatius was a knight, etc.,
etc. They were all crusaders.
>> Mhm. Now, didn't Hexet say that or
didn't he write a book, The American
Crusade, and doesn't he have the
Crusader emblems on it? We've discussed
all of that. So, nothing has changed.
No.
>> So, have they succeeded in this
counterreformation?
>> Yes. Unfortunately, very much so,
because like we've mentioned now, the
whole time they infiltrated even the
word of God.
>> Yes. So, Ignatius gathered around him
six men and they took special vows and
due to his military upbringing and the
fact that the society's men members were
willing to accept any mission anywhere
in the world and become soldiers in the
interests of the faith and their church.
So, they're a military order, right?
>> The first lines of their order founding
charter states that the society of Jesus
was suitable for whoever desires to
serve as a soldier of God. Let's correct
that soldier of the papacy.
>> Yeah,
>> they're lying. They're not serving God.
They're serving the devil.
>> That um video that guy said that it's
all about denying the authority of the
church.
>> Correct. And Ignatius was their first
leader. The title which he took is
superior general and he has it to this
day.
And uh if you want to know their art of
war then go and look at cre to Malta and
you will see uh that's one of our video
series that they can do this quite
adequately.
Ignatius wrote his vision for the
exceptional order he had founded on a
document called the formula of the
institute of the society of Jesus. This
was the founding document for the order
to which all other documents had to
conform.
Ignatius Laval Lyola then made sure that
his formula was anchored in papal law,
definitely not biblical law, by the
signing of two paperal bills, one in
1540 by Pope Paul III and another in
1550 by Pope Julius III. And the formula
described the nature and purpose of the
new order and the kind of spirituality
and community that they will build which
was not biblical but based on
spiritualism.
>> Yes.
>> And it is the worship of demons
>> and it's so infiltrated in Christianity
in Protestantism that it's nauseating.
>> Yes. And you can't detect it because uh
it has all kinds of forms. And whether
we're talking about purpose-driven
churches or whatever, they all run to
the papacy. [snorts]
And uh we don't have to go into the
history that is well known. Whether
we're talking about crystal palace of of
Schula, [snorts] which eventually of
course became a crystal palace of the
Roman Catholic Church
>> and basically they just transferred it
to the original real owners.
>> Yeah.
So the Jesuits claimed that the reform
of the church had to begin with the
individual's conversion of heart to what
to the spiritual exercises which lead
you to
>> accepting the pope as your spiritual
guide. [clears throat]
>> The Jesuits believe that Ignatius
retreat the spiritual exercises is one
of the ways to bring this conversion
about. The retreat lasts four weeks. It
is a period of silence during which one
practices a series of direct meditations
on the life of Jesus. So you don't
speak, you just meditate, but you don't
meditate on the word. You have a literal
experience with the spiritual world.
>> Yes. With your senses.
>> Yes. and Protestants
and some uh misdirected people probably
maybe from our own ranks will take part
in this nonsense. Stay away.
>> So in the Catholic Church today, the
Jesuits are one of the largest religious
order of priests and brothers. So the
current general is Adula Nicholas.
That's a little bit outdated on the
Vatican page. They should update it to
Soua or whoever the next one will be.
They probably know already who it's
going to be so that they can face the
scripture one day and the wroth of the
lamb.
Revelation chapter 17. And there came
one of the seven angels which had the
seven vials and talked with me, saying
unto me, come hither, I will show unto
thee the judgment of the great
that sitth upon many waters.
There's not a Protestant in the previous
century who didn't know who this was
referring to. It was the papacy. Yeah.
She was the great that sits
amongst the nations
with whom the kings of the earth to this
very day by the way
>> that's a main thing
>> have committed fornication and the
inhabitants of the earth have been made
drunk with the wine of her fornication
her false doctrines
>> unfortunately we're seeing this now
everywhere
>> yes
>> I mean in the speeches that's why we've
shown them some of them and we probably
will again on these speeches just on the
Charlie Kirk memorial moral.
>> Yes. Amazing.
>> Definitely.
>> In Revelation 13, and I stood upon the
sand of the sea, and I saw a beast, a
political entity, rise up out of the
sea, out of the nations, having seven
heads and 10 horns, and upon his horns,
10 crowns. This is the period when Rome
had been divided into the European
nations. And the Roman Catholic Church
claimed supremacy and put the crowns on
the horns. And she was the prominent
horn in the middle that controlled
conscience.
>> Yeah. And still does.
>> And what was it like? This horn and upon
his head the name of blasphemy. It was a
blasphemous power because it claimed
infallibility and said it was the way to
salvation through their sacramental
systems etc. which have zero merit
because only a transformed heart has
merit.
In the book, The Great Controversy, we
read the following. A prayerful study of
the Bible would show Protestants the
real character of the papacy and would
cause them to abhore and to shun it.
>> Not go into ecumenical council with it.
>> Exactly.
let alone become vice chairs of their
ecumenical council, bowing before altars
and pretending to bless people through
this paganistic culture.
>> But many are so wise in their own
conceit that they feel no need of humbly
seeking God that they may be led into
the truth. Although priding themselves
on their enlightenment, they are
ignorant both of the scripture and of
the power of God. Martin, you cannot
align yourself with the system that has
written Christ out of the mediation.
>> No. Not not even to do to do good.
>> No. And no matter how pompous your
ceremonies are [clears throat] and how
many vestments you wear and how many
doilies you put on your head and how
many legal blocks you attach to your
body and sashes, it's not going to
impress anyone, especially not Christ.
>> No.
>> He says he's not a respector of persons.
>> No. So modern the iceberg that we have
to meet
is a false theology. That's why the
everlasting gospel had to be preached
again.
>> An entire false system of religion which
has been based on compromise and which
is going to make void God's law and make
the authority in their life the papal
system because his wound has to heal.
And Protestantism is going to give him
that power.
>> Yeah. And the you and the Jesuit order
has infiltrated everything any every
aspect of life in bringing this about.
>> Correct. And now Martin the issue the
final issue we've said it a long time
ago is therefore the authority of God
and his mediation.
>> Now the only commandment that absolutely
pinpoints the authority of God is the
Sabbath commandment
>> and it describes who this God is.
Correct. So it tells you who the God is
and why he has jurisdiction over your
life because he created you in six days.
He created the heavens and the earth and
therefore he commanded you to keep the
Sabbath day
>> and you were not supposed to work on
that day. Right.
>> Mhm.
>> And then if you go to the book of
Deuteronomy then you read the same ten
commandments there because he's your
redeemer. He saved you out of slavery
>> symbolically Egypt. But the real uh
saving was out of the idolatry of sin.
>> He was the creator and he's the
recreator.
>> Correct? So you read in Ezekiel
20:12.
Now please be reminded that Ezekiel was
a prophet of the exile. He was an exile
himself.
>> Yeah. In Babylon.
>> Yes. Jeremiah was the prophet in
Jerusalem telling them what they were
doing was wrong and breaking the
Sabbath. And he has a whole chapter on
why they were breaking the Sabbath. And
they threw him into the dungeons and
threw him into the mer and they treated
him like a dog.
So Ezekiel said, "Moreover, I also gave
them my Sabbaths to be a sign between me
and them that they might know that I am
the Lord that sanctifies them." There
you have the whole shooting match there.
>> So where does your sanctification and
your mediation come from?
>> From Christ.
>> Christ. From the Lord.
>> Yeah.
>> Isaiah chapter 58. He's Lord. And
therefore he gave them the Sabbath.
>> Okay. So
>> So which is the Lord's day? the Sabbath.
According to Isaiah chapter 15,
>> he's Lord of the Sabbath.
>> You have to call it the Lord's day
honorable, the Sabbath.
Ezekiel 20:20 says, "Hello, my Sabbath,
and there shall be a sign between me and
you, that you may know that I am the
Lord your God." So, the Roman Catholic
Church will try and convince you that
the covenant is now a new covenant
>> and that the the day has been changed.
>> Yeah. By their authority. by their
authority. What a load of dril if I may
use that term.
>> So modern that if that were the case
then God is not changeless.
>> No. Then he changed because he was
different when he wrote when he Ezekiel
wrote write this.
>> So the Jews were keeping the letter of
the law and he said I'll change to a new
covenant
>> and I'll write it on your hearts.
Does that mean he's going to ch write a
different law on your heart?
>> That's what people say and what they
say. But no, it cannot be.
>> How do you know he didn't write a
different law on his heart? Doesn't he
say in Matthew chapter 5 that not one
jot or one tit will disappear out of the
law? Exactly. And if you touch one of
the least of the commandments, you're
going to be in trouble. Doesn't he say
that?
>> He says exactly that.
>> So where do they come across this
nonsense that they are preaching that
the new covenant is different from the
old? It's to wangle and change it again
to put the them in authority and not
God.
>> Correct? And you don't have to change.
>> You only have to keep a sacrament. And
if you are a Jew, go and sit in
Jerusalem and you're saved. What
nonsense is that? You have to change.
>> So, Exodus 31:17
tells us that this Sabbath
>> is a sign
>> between me and the children of Israel
forever. For in six days the Lord made
the heaven and the earth and the seventh
day he rested and he was refreshed. And
the word sign if you look it up in the
concordance says it is the mark the
distinguishing mark of his power. Right?
So Martin when we face this iceberg over
there
>> the iceberg is not just Sabbath.
>> No
>> the iceberg is the entire doctrinal
position that has been taken by the
world contrary to God. In other words,
the everlasting gospel. But your sign of
allegiance to the original is that you
keep the Sabbath.
>> Yes. You You're going to struggle if you
throw that one away.
>> Yes.
>> Because your anchor is gone.
>> You're not going to be able to stand.
>> So, will we be able to stand? Well,
number one, you have to have the true
gospel. That's why the first angel says
the everlasting gospel must be preached
again which stands on two legs
>> which is salvation in Christ and
obedience to his commands because if you
love him you will keep his commandments
and if you don't you're a liar
>> and it's equal legs.
>> Yes
>> not one stronger than the other.
>> Justice and mercy kissed each other. The
mercy seat, which is your shielding from
the condemnation of the law, was as high
in height as the grill or grid of the
altar of burnt offering. You can't make
God's justice less than his mercy
>> and vice versa.
>> Vice versa, they come together. They're
a package. Take it or leave it.
>> So, what did God do? He says, "Okay,
Israel, I'm going to divide you into two
groups. So one group go and stand on
that hill, the other group stand on this
hill. And let me tell you what's going
to happen. If you are obedient to my
commandments, then the following is
going to happen. All these blessings
will come upon you. And if you're not
going to be obedient to my commandments,
all these curses are going to come upon
you. So we just read about the trumpets,
all those curses that came upon them.
>> And I gave them time, I mean 1,260
years time to repent. And they would
>> not
>> they would not. And to this day they
would
>> not
>> not and Babylon has fallen has fallen.
Now Rome fell early on when it replaced
Jesus with an earthly priesthood. It's
been fallen for millennia. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> Who fell the second time?
>> Protestantism.
>> Ah.
>> So that's why Babylon has fallen has
fallen because he's gone back to Rome.
>> Yeah. Some of them have introduced the
mass [snorts] and the Protestants think,
well, this is so cool. We'll partake in
this eukarist as well and they go and
munch on an idol piece of bread which is
totally meaningless.
>> Mhm.
>> And uh have you ever read the book 50
years in the church of Rome?
>> No, not completely. Yeah,
>> it's a wonderful book where he was a
Roman Catholic priest and he was
horrified
>> when the host fell into the urine pot
that was under the bed or when rats came
and ate it. So this is where it leads to
until you eventually realize that this
is all hocus pocus nonsense.
>> And the reformers were willing to die.
>> Yes.
>> Rather than to accept the doctrine of
transsubstantiation.
>> I can understand why because it's
heresy. is idolatry. All right. So the
mark [clears throat]
of who you follow and who you believe,
whether you believe that he is your
creator and that he is your sanctifier
and your redeemer and your stamp, your
mark of allegiance to those statements
is the Sabbath. That's up to you as an
individual.
So in the Sabbath commandment which is
called the seal of God as we just read
you have the name of the creator Yave.
You have his title creator and you have
his territory heaven and earth.
>> Yeah.
>> And if you pray the Lord's prayer it
says thy kingdom come thy will be done
on earth as it is in heaven. Is his will
being done on earth at the moment?
>> No.
>> Are they going to try and bring about a
millennium peace and try and enforce
that will?
>> Yes. Is it their will or is is it God's
will or paper will?
>> It's papal will.
>> Martin, the world is so deceived.
>> So in Exodus 3:9, it shall be for a sign
unto thee upon thine hand and for a
memorial between thine eyes, that the
Lord's law may be in thy mouth. So what
must be on your forehead and on your
hand?
>> The law.
>> The law. Does that include the Sabbath?
>> Yes. You must live it. I thought it was
a computer stamp,
>> a digital ID.
>> Yeah. Um
CBC, the CBDC, central [clears throat]
central business banking.
>> Didn't Stramma just say that he's going
to introduce it by the end of the of the
year
>> and if you don't take it, you can't
partake in the economy and you better
starve to death. So if they bring in
with that uh it's against that it should
be against God and you should keep the
Sunday and all of this
>> then they have the means to enforce it.
>> That's what
>> but it doesn't become the mark the means
to enforce it.
>> Yes. Because we've clearly seen that a
mark is to show whose authority you
belong to.
>> So the Lord's law
>> must be on your forehead and on your
hand. But they say can be on your
forehead and your hand. They don't care
whether you just obey them or whether
you think they're right.
>> Yeah.
>> So, the Roman Catholic Church said, "Sun
Sunday is our mark of authority." I know
this is old news,
>> but this is the iceberg that we're
heading for.
>> Exactly.
>> The church is above the Bible, and this
transference of Sabbath observance is
proof of that fact. That's the Roman
Catholic Church stating it. And Father
Enright said, "The Bible says, remember
that thou keep the Sabbath day, holy the
Sabbath day." The Catholic Church says,
"No.
By my divine power, that's a blasphemy.
I abolish the Sabbath day and command
you to keep holy the first day of the
week. And then he sarcastically says the
entire civilized world bows down to the
reverent obedience to the command of the
holy Catholic Church. I refuse to do
that.
>> And there hopefully will be an
irritating
group.
>> Yes. getting together and saying exactly
that this is not on
>> a thorn in their flesh.
>> Now if a thorn is irritating you in your
flesh, what is your tendency? What would
you want to do with a thorn?
>> Pluck it out.
>> Get rid of it. Right. Make
[clears throat] sure it doesn't get into
your flesh again. Are we heading for
that?
>> Well, didn't we hear when we had that
discussion that um
>> it'll be the lesser of two evils?
>> Yes. the majority will be keeping this
and it will be uncomfortable for the
other ones.
>> Okay.
So, Sunday is a Catholic institution and
its claims to observance can be defended
only on Catholic principles. And then
they say from the beginning to the end
of scripture. There's not a single
passage which warrants the transfer from
the seventh day to the first. So they
know that the scripture is not in
harmony with their tradition. I gave
them time to repent, but they
>> would not.
>> They would not. So, I will put them on a
bed of suffering.
>> They think they're going to put God's
people on a bed of suffering. But, uh,
when that gospel ship hits that iceberg,
there will be a shaking in the gospel
ship, but there will be those that have
their seat belts on.
>> It's going to be worse for the iceberg
than for those that keep on and clinging
to the ship.
>> Correct.
So if Protestants would follow the
Bible, they should worship God on the
Sabbath day.
In keeping the Sunday, they are
following a law of the Catholic Church.
I mean, these are all Catholic quotes.
>> It's interesting that they they refer to
it as the Sabbath day.
>> Yes, but they're lying, of course.
>> No. Well, they changed it. You remember
there was this video doing the rounds
now about um the new pope um that said
keep the holy Saturday.
>> Yeah. That's just one of their liturgy
days. That
>> it's important. Can you just explain a
little bit? Because that got a lot of
people confused.
>> I know they shouldn't get confused
because the Catholic Church has never
denied
>> exactly
>> that the Sabbath is the true uh holy
day, but they will direct you to the
Sunday
>> which they call the Lord's day. Why?
>> Because they say that they've got the
authority to change it.
>> Correct. And they will remind you once a
year
>> Mhm.
>> that uh God actually had a different
day. And then it's in their system it's
a holy Saturday where they commemorate
the rest
>> the creation and the rest.
>> So what they are actually doing is a
blasphemy [clears throat]
>> because they are saying we know which
day it is. Here it is. Let me just tell
you about it. Don't worry about it.
Nobody stop work please because we're
just reminding you that we changed it
but we're going to force you to stop
working on Sunday.
>> It's very good. is actually a smoke.
>> It's a smoke. It's a disgrace.
So, Protestantism in discarding the
authority of the Roman Catholic Church
has no good reason for its Sunday theory
and ought logically to keep Saturday as
the Sabbath. Interesting. That's the
American Quarterly Review.
And then they say it quite openly. Most
Christians assume that Sunday is the
biblical approved day of worship. But
the Roman Catholic Church protests
because it transferred the Christian
worship from the biblical Sabbath
Saturday. They even put it in brackets
so that you don't forget to Sunday. And
that to try to argue that the change was
made in the Bible is both dishonest and
a denial of Catholic authority. Now,
don't Protestants use the Bible? Yes,
they I mean we had um Douglas Wilson and
Lenox tell us no, it was a transferal in
the Bible.
>> Yes.
>> And they quote text totally out of
context. Right.
>> Completely.
>> So if Protestantism wants to base its
teachings on the Bible, it should
worship on Saturday.
So the converts catechism says which is
the Sabbath? Saturday is the Sabbath.
Why do we observe Sunday? because the
Catholic Church transferred it to
Sunday. And then in his loati, the pope
says Sunday like the Jewish Sabbath,
which is absolute nonsense because the
Sabbath was there long before there was
a Jew was there in E.
>> It is for mankind.
>> Yes. Is meant to be a day which heals
our relationship with God, with
ourselves, and with others, and with the
world. The law of weekly rest forbade
work on the seventh day. And then he
goes into details as to why that was so.
>> And then he says you must keep the
Sunday.
>> Sunday. Yeah.
>> Okay. So, is he drunk from his own wine?
>> Wine of Babylon.
>> Yes. I think he's got a shot or two in
that wine.
>> Well, they've the latest pope has
blessed ice cube so he can use that in
his drink.
>> Do you think it'll fit in? Was quite a
big drink. quite a big glass that you
won't need because it's a big ice block.
Anyway, recovering the Sabbath and this
is now Brett Mccclaclin. We've shown
this one also before and uh these
despicable letters behind it SJ Society
of Jesus Jesuits. Then he tells us quite
frankly that this paper which he's
writing here advances that the religion
state model of cooperationism
would allow for civil legislation to
protect the Sabbath.
>> Not this biblical Sabbath,
>> their Sabbath,
>> the Sunday Sabbath.
>> So does he want church and state to work
together on this issue?
>> Oh, definitely.
>> All right. So then he talks about the
bill of rights and he says fortunately
you know countries like Germany they
recognize the universal common good. So
this legislation where republicanism
>> and separation of church and state comes
into conflict with this ideology.
Fortunately the other nations in Europe
are not restricted by these so-called
republican documents.
And then the Judeo-Christian tradition
may be the source of advocacy for Sunday
closing laws. You see, now he's talking
about Sunday.
>> Yeah.
>> Yet a weekly rest from the economy
serves all citizens. So there's your
common good.
>> Common good.
>> So like all Je Jesuits, he's totally
apostate, anti-biblical, proapacy,
belongs to Antichrist.
And that's why the Catechism of the
Church could say quite openly that in
respecting religious liberty and the
common good of all Christians should
seek recognition of Sunday and the
church's holy days as legal holidays.
And if you don't listen, if you violate
the sanctity of Sunday, you must be
punished as a heretic. So basically,
John Paul already says we must kill all
Sabbathke keepers.
>> Yeah. Because
>> except Jews
>> because they will have their own
country.
>> Mhm.
>> Where they can live under their laws.
But anybody who keeps the Sabbath and is
not a Jew and lives in their
jurisdiction will be subject to
punishment.
>> That's very well planned if you can put
it like that.
>> Oh, they've been planning this for
decades. No, for centuries. They've
opened up a country where they can go
and worship
and keep the Sabbath and be unscathed.
They got a lot of support and now with
Trump opening the way with a peace plan,
this is really getting interesting.
>> It's getting very interesting indeed.
So, Ucius in his ecclesiastical history
wrote uh about spiritual Israel that
fled to Pella and he calls them the
spiritual seed of Abraham because the
Bible said if you be in Christ
then you be the spiritual seed of
Abraham and hes according to the
promise. So this just that statement of
spiritual Israel makes it that the whole
world
>> yes
>> is has to be adherent to what they say
is Jewish Sabbath and it's not true.
>> Now the interesting thing it says here
in this quote where they found a safe
place of refuge and could serve their
master and keep his Sabbath. M
>> now this quote actually comes from from
Sabbath to Sunday Bakayoki's book which
received the impromptto of the Jesuit
in charge of the university in Rome the
Jesuit university
>> the top university of the Jesuits in the
world and he was the only Protestant who
was allowed to do a thesis of this
nature because biblically
He showed quite clearly that the Sabbath
had been changed and Rome doesn't have a
problem with that.
>> No, ex they actually enjoy it.
>> Yes, that's what we've seen from all
their previous ones. So, they gave them
their stamp of approval. Uh, one
unfortunate thing in the last chapters
is that he refers to the Sunday as the
Lord's day with no biblical proof
whatsoever. That's actually why they the
the Roman Catholic Church probably gave
the stamp because if that wasn't
>> yes
>> in there they wouldn't have given it.
>> So this is a little bit problematic but
be that as it may the Jesuits approved
everything that was written in in that.
And uh if we were to say the same things
they would also approve it as we saw.
>> Yeah.
>> Because except I wouldn't say the last
thing. I would stick to the biblical
Lord's day.
>> Exactly. So what did the Protestants
actually say about the scriptures? Well,
the Presbyterians in their documents
claim that a change of the day to be
observed from the last day of the week
to the first that there's no record, no
command authorizing this change. So they
recognize it.
>> So the Methodists the same. Take the
matter of Sunday. There's no passage
telling Christians to keep that day. So
my question is Martin, why do the modern
Protestants keep quoting texts when the
Methodists say there's no text?
>> Because they distort them and take them
out of context.
>> Okay, so there's no text that transfers
the Jewish Sabbath to the first day of
the week. The Anglicans, they say the
same thing. Many people think that
Sunday is the Sabbath. Neither the New
Testament nor the early church is there
anything to suggest that we have any
right to transfer the observance. Isn't
that interesting? The Sabbath was on
each Saturday and not Sunday. That's
their Anglican
document. The Baptists, and by the way,
it's in the Baptist manual. It can't get
any better than that. There was and is a
commandment to keep holy the Sabbath,
but that Sabbath day was not Sunday.
There's no scriptural evidence that the
change was made, right? None. None.
So when we look at the texts,
>> yeah, the ones that the
>> that the modern Protestants try to use
under the instigation of Jesuit
teaching, [clears throat]
>> then they will quote these eight verses.
Matthew 28:1. And in the end of the
Sabbath, as it began to dawn towards the
first day of the week, came Mary
Magdalene and the other Mary to see the
sephila.
Does that change the day of worship? No,
that's a historic statement.
>> Okay. Why Why didn't they come on the
Saturday which was after the
crucifixion?
>> Because they were resting on the Sabbath
day
>> and they were keeping the commandments
according
>> to the law.
>> To the law. Okay.
>> So,
>> so it's just a historical statement.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, I think it's not there
arbitrarily. I think it's there in on
purpose.
>> Okay. And when the Sabbath was passed,
says Mark, and he actually tells you
that Mary Magdalene,
mother of James and Salon, had brought
sweet spices that they might come and
anoint him. So, it was a common working
day for them, right?
>> The Sunday.
>> Yeah. But they didn't do it on the
Sabbath. So, it's just a historic fact.
There's no change of worship here.
>> No. It's actually um acknowledging the
>> the Sabbath.
>> The Sabbath.
>> Yeah.
And then Mark also says and very early
in the morning in the first day of the
week they came unto the sephila at the
rising of the sun. This is a historic
statement.
Luke says now upon the first day of the
week very early in the morning they came
unto the sephila bringing the spices
which they had prepared and certain
others with them. Historical statement.
Now it gets interesting. John 20 verse
one. And the first day of the week
cometh Mary Magdalene early when it was
yet dark unto the seila and sees the
stone taken away from the seila. So
what's interesting here is while it was
yet dark
>> because the Sabbath goes from sunset to
sunset. So when the sun had set after
the Sabbath,
>> they could have gone right then.
>> Yeah. But
>> because it was the first day, but they
wouldn't be able to see anything. It's
too dark. Too dark. And
>> they didn't have a street light.
at that point, nor did they have a
torch, just a lantern.
>> Yeah.
>> But they came while it was still dark so
that they could immediately proceed to
do what they wanted to do when it was
light.
>> Yeah.
>> They obviously didn't think about the
big stone that was ahead there. They
just wanted to get to the body of Jesus.
Now, let's look to these verses. Then
that same day at evening because Jesus
had said do not detain me. I have not
yet gone to my father. So that blows the
thief
on the right hand side of Christ who
said remember me when you get to your
kingdom. And Jesus said uh verily verily
I say unto thee today
>> you will be with me in the kingdom. Or
verily verily I say today you will be in
the kingdom. That blows that argument
out of the water.
because obviously he he hadn't been to
the father yet.
>> Yes. So there's no going directly to
heaven after death.
>> Then the same day at evening. So Jesus
had res been resurrected. He said do not
detain me. I have not yet been to the
father. I go
>> and I will come back. Go and prepare the
disciples. So that same evening which
was Sunday evening being the first day
of the week when the doors were shut
where the disciples were assembled for
fear of the Jews. So did they uh have a
worship session to celebrate the
resurrection?
>> Not at all. They were hiding.
>> Okay. They weren't afraid on the Sabbath
day. Why not?
>> Because they knew that the Jews will not
do anything to
>> They wouldn't defile themselves.
>> They'll be resting.
>> But they were pretty scared on the first
day of the week. And so they assembled
to hide themselves.
>> So this is not a church gathering.
>> Definitely not. This is a fear
gathering.
Then Jesus came and stood in their midst
and said unto them, "Peace be unto you."
>> Okay. So there's no Sunday worship here.
>> No.
>> All right. Acts 20:7. And upon the first
day of the week, when the disciples came
together to break bread, Paul preached
unto them, ready to depart on the
tomorrow. and continued his speech until
midnight.
Oh, so they were having a a good old
church service there. Right now, let's
unpack it carefully.
When the disciples came together to
break bread, there are parallel texts
which says they came together every day
to break bread.
>> Yes. Every single day they came to get
that doesn't make this day special.
>> And Paul preached to them ready to
depart on the tomorrow. Okay.
>> So, when did they come together? After
the Sabbath closed.
>> They after the Sabbath closed, they came
together to have a meal.
>> Okay.
>> And Paul arrived.
>> And he continued his speech until
midnight.
>> So, the Sabbath ended the Saturday
evening.
>> Yes.
>> At sunset.
>> And he preached until midnight. Now,
another text will tell you there were
many lights there because it was already
dark. So what they had is a church
meeting after sunset.
But the papacy doesn't celebrate Sunday
from sunset to sunset because that would
be a little bit too biblical even for
another day.
>> So they changed it from midnight to
midnight. Right?
>> Okay. Now if this was such a holy day
now and had replaced the Sabbath, then
my question is what was he going to do?
Why did he preach until midnight on the
first day of the week?
>> In other words, after sunset, Sabbath
[snorts]
until midnight? Because he said to them,
"I'm going on a long journey tomorrow."
So, was he going to violate their Sunday
by going on a long journey?
>> Yes, he would have if that was to be
kept holy.
>> Correct. And they had kept Sabbath that
whole day. And now they're in a meeting
until midnight. And poor old Uticus
>> was a little bit tired and fell out the
window.
Right.
>> Yeah.
>> So all of this drama happened at night,
>> Saturday evening.
>> Yes. It wasn't a Sunday worship service.
And now the collecting. 1 Corinthians
16. Now concerning the collection for
the saints, as I've given orders to the
churches of Galatia, so do ye. Upon the
first day of the week, let everyone of
you lay by him in store. Now some of the
translations will will make it clear
that this is not in a church setting but
at home.
>> Yeah.
>> So everyone lay at home
your offering
>> on the first day.
>> On the first day as God has prospered
you at there be no gathering when I
come. I don't want the church collection
when I come. So these people earned
their salary on a weekly basis. They got
their salary on a Friday.
>> That was preparation day. No time to
work with finances because the Sabbath
was coming.
>> Yeah. After work quickly, get ready for
keeping the Sabbath.
>> Correct. And then when the Sabbath is
over, that could be Saturday night.
>> Mhm.
>> After sunset. Well, then you can go and
say, "How much am I prepared of this
salary to give to the Lord? Lay it aside
in your house." This was no church
service. This is a total distortion of
the fact. In fact, they were to do it at
home and they were to keep it there.
>> Yeah.
>> And not give it to anyone and then when
he comes, they can all bring their
donation for the church. And the other
text that they all hang their hopes on
is Colossians 2. We're just doing this
for completeness because we've done it
so many times. We're going to run
through it
>> just to put it in the package.
>> It's talking here about the handwriting
of ordinances. You cannot read
Colossians 2:16 without reading 2:14.
>> Correct. Or without reading Ephesians
where he refers to the same handwriting
of ordinances which was the law of
Moses.
>> Yeah.
>> Which was not in the ark but beside the
ark. It's the ceremonial law. And he
claims here that this handwriting of
ordinance, the ceremonial law was nailed
to the cross.
>> And that was written against them.
>> Yes. And so having spoiled
principalities and powers, he made a
show of them openly, triumphing them
over them in the cross because he
fulfilled the ceremonial law. He
triumphed over it. He became the
mediator.
>> He had paid the price for sin. Let no
man therefore judge you in meat or drink
or in respect to a holy day, a new moon,
or the Sabbath days, plural.
Now some of the modern Roman Catholic
influenced uh translation will make that
the Sabbath day with a capital letter
and not plural like here Sabbath days.
And these Sabbath days had to do with
eating and drinking. So they were
ceremonial laws and had nothing to do
with the seventh day Sabbath
>> which had nothing about eating or
drinking in them. So what were these
referring to? They were a shadow of
things to come.
>> Yeah. What was the shadow of
>> Christ?
>> The body is of Christ. So it was
pointing ahead to Christ. Let no man
beguile you of your reward in a
voluntary humility and worshiping of
angels, intruding into those things
which he has not seen vainly puffed up
by his fleshly mind. So the ceremonial
law referring to the sacrifice of Christ
with its ceremonial Sabbaths are no
longer binding. Nothing to do with the
Sabbath,
>> nothing to do with the weekly Sabbath,
>> nothing. So when Revelation warns us in
the third angel's message that we must
avoid
uh the beast and his image and the mark
of the beast and the forehead, the beast
and the image and the image is the same
kind of system that ruled in the middle
ages. Church and state coming together.
And today we have Protestant America
saying church and state must come
together and we must introduce moral
legislation
including as we discussed with uh Lenox
and with Douglas Wilson
including
Sabbath.
>> Yeah.
>> Their Sunday.
And therefore you have to avoid this
image. Now image is something that looks
like the original.
>> Mhm. And Protestantism is very much like
the original
because it has basically by joining up
with Rome set aside the mediation of
Christ and accepted accepted the
sperious mediation.
>> Yeah. So meaning they are very much like
the original. The original being Roman
Catholicism.
>> Exactly. And so we mustn't accept the
mark. And they said our mark of
authority is Sunday worship. So I cannot
accept Sunday worship because that makes
the pope the authority.
>> I have to accept the Sabbath which makes
God the authority.
>> I cannot accept the mediation of a pope
or of a church or of a uh walking a
labyrinth or exercise of Lyola
talking to demons and pretending that
they're angels or Mary or whatever. My
mediation comes from Christ and Christ
alone. So this image of the beast, this
conglomerate of false teachings mixed
with the power of the state, I have to
avoid it.
>> Mhm.
>> And I have to avoid the mark of the
beast where the beast itself says that
it's
>> Sunday.
>> Well, if you do, then you will drink of
the wine of the wroth of God which is
poured without mixture. In other words,
there will be no mercy. It will be over.
This is the final test. This is the
iceberg.
>> This is it
>> that we have to meet. And uh in
Revelation 18, we are told that the
system,
this image of the beast has become a
house of demons.
>> Yeah. So
>> because they're not preaching the
original gospel of Jesus Christ
>> and they even though they look like they
are a Christian
authority
>> invoking the name of Jesus doesn't make
you Christian. Catholicism invokes the
name of Jesus but denies the atonement.
Right.
>> Yeah. Protestantism
believes that by invoking the Holy
Spirit, which is supposed to lead you to
repentance and to faith in Jesus Christ,
will give you gold fillings, lots of
money, and a prosperity here on earth
and the power to rule over everyone
else, which is just as ridiculous as
what was believed by Rome in the Middle
Ages.
>> Yes, same problem.
>> So, what happens when you replace the
simple gospel with this? Well, then you
become a hold of every foul spirit and a
cage of every unclean and hateful bird.
That's a false holy spirit,
an unclean spirit that is leading you
astray and leading you to accept a
spirious
obedience
>> to a biblical obedience.
Why? Because the nations have been made
drunk
by the wine of the wroth of her
fornication.
They have drunken her doctrines and are
willing to compromise on that level.
>> They've
>> Didn't they compromise on the doctrine
of justification?
>> Yes, they've already done all this
compromise.
>> All of it is done. And the kings of the
earth have committed fornication with
Isn't church and state coming together?
>> Definitely.
>> And the merchants of the earth are waxed
rich through the abundance of a
delicacy. Do we see that?
>> Oh. Well, in part two, we can show that
all of these things have actually
happened, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And then I heard another voice from
heaven saying, "Come out of her, my
people." Don't have anything to do with
a false system of worship that
compromises your faith in Christ.
So, let's wrap it up. Martin, the
Sabbath will be the great test of
loyalty, for it is the point of truth
especially controverted.
When the final test shall be brought to
bear upon men, then the line of
distinction will be drawn between those
who serve God and those who serve him
not. It's not an issue only of the day.
It's a package deal.
>> Whose authority, right?
>> That's it. Here to fall those who
presented the truths of the third
angel's message which says do not accept
the mark of the beast but the
righteousness of Christ right have often
been regarded as mere alarmists. Their
predictions that religious intolerance
would gain control in the United States
that church and state would unite to
persecute those who keep the
commandments of God have been pronounced
groundless and absurd. Martin, haven't
we shown over that they're not
groundless, nor are they absurd,
>> and they're all the more getting into
line right now.
>> So, are we going to meet an iceberg?
>> It's up ahead.
>> So, Martin, let's face the iceberg.
Let's pray that the Lord will give us
the strength not only to face the
iceberg, but to stay on the ship.
>> That's why we can in the second part, we
can definitely discuss on how we'll be
be able to stand.
>> Yes. to when we hit that.
>> Shall we close in prayer?
>> Yes.
>> Heavenly Father,
we have done a quick recap of history
and of the terrible apostasy which wrote
you out of the plan of salvation and
replaced it with earthly powers.
Father in heaven, give us wisdom to
concentrate on the word. Because man
does not live by bread alone, but by
every word that proceeds out of the
mouth of God. Give us the strength to
believe it, to live it, and to face any
opposition to it. Is my prayer in Jesus'
name. Amen. Amen. [music]
>> [music]
>> Heat. Heat.
>> Where's